maletas llenas de dulces té y otros
productos ingleses allison y davis
preparan los últimos detalles de su
viaje uno que los conducirá a
reencontrarse con su hijo liam a quien
lo han visto desde 2019
se sintió como una vida entera todos los
días hemos estado revisando las noticias
en los periódicos
y escuchando la radio para saber cuándo
eeuu abría sus fronteras para nosotros
con la apertura de las fronteras de eeuu
este lunes muchas familias separadas por
la pandemia podrán reunirse con sus
seres queridos tras cerca de dos años de
espera
nos perdimos su cumpleaños número 30 a
pesar de que no pensábamos en una gran
celebración nos perdimos eso y después
tuvo su primer trabajo en eeuu lo que es
muy importante
eeuu cerró sus fronteras para el turismo
y viajeros no esenciales en marzo de
2020 ahora la nueva política establece
que los viajeros tendrán que tener la
pauta completa de vacunación para poder
entrar al territorio estadounidense
la determinación va de la mano con la
reapertura el mes pasado de las
fronteras terrestres con méxico y canadá
una apuesta del gobierno estadounidense
para impulsar de nuevo el turismo en el
país